some omega-3 a la la la la' bet that was
really I just heard that I thought up
hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen today's what a
need a youtuber review is a rose from
cheap lazy vegan so Rose is a fellow
Canadian so of course very proud and
I've watched a lot of her videos and I
like love her personality she's got lots
of vegan recipes some vegan meal prep
lots of what I eat a day videos
she's got vegan mukbangs which I don't
love and I find those problematic but I
will save that rant for another day but
I also have heard that she's just about
to open or if she has opened a
restaurant called Savage cafe so very
awesome
so this is one of roses more recent what
I need a videos since I started working
on this one I saw that she released
another one that's kind of a
intermittent fasting fitness challenge
and I thought about scrapping what I was
been working on and and and doing the
recent one however knowing that it's a
fitness challenge it felt kind of unfair
because I know what I know about
challenges and diets is that they're not
sustainable and probably if she's like
everyone else she'd be back to eating
her normal way in no time
after the challenge is up so I figured
that this was a more fair assessment of
Rosa's diet so let's get to it first of
all can we just say I love the logo
because my Elsa loves noodles so
[Music]
all right before we even get into this I
just need to like take a moment to
appreciate roses hair because while most
vegans I feel really do preach you know
the importance of greens Row is like a
body screen and I'm liking this I'm I
don't I couldn't pull it off that's for
sure
but she looks great I think it's fun
let's do this you holiday you know let's
keep it let's keep a healthy today oh
girl I hear ya
I I just love her I just love her but
like here's the dealio on holiday weight
gain there is research on this and what
it has shown is that most people on
average gain a little bit of weight one
point three pounds honestly in my books
not linked totally stress about but I
would say that like if you go into the
holiday season with like a cheat meal or
like a cheat season mentality you're
bound to just overeat past your satiety
signals and then spend the entire year
after that trying to kind of like repent
and restrict as a way to make up for you
know what you would just kind of eaten
during the holidays but if you would
just kind of like listen to your body's
cues it would be much easier to have
like mindful moderate portions of all
your favorite holiday foods without
filling the need to completely overdo it
so let's keep healthy today hopefully
very delicious because I know what she's
saying and that was a totally dietician
approved philosophy you don't need to
skip out on flavor and pleasure in order
for things to be well balanced and to
fuel your body right
had my coffee as usual so when I
immediately wake up I don't normally eat
breakfast right away well obviously
depending on what time I wake up today I
woke up a bit later than I usually do a
workup at seven o'clock and I had my
coffee and I did some work Makapuu tea
I'm gonna talk about the more after this
because I'm starting to get hungry guys
I'm gonna make myself a smoothie and
okay so what I'm hearing Rose talk about
seems like a really intuitive way to
think about food she's not following a
crazy restrictive diet she's not fasting
until late she's simply just waiting for
her body to feel ready to be interested
in food and that's great if it works for
her it works for me the little jar so
smoothies the first meal a day I mean
great accessible easy Lisa's not juice
which is unusual for you know vegan
youtubers I have been noticing so yeah
let's take a look what's inside because
I'm sick and tired of carrying out like
ten bags of things when I am making
smoothie so if you like to add a lot of
things that your smoothie
I suggest Porsche so I cropped like four
of these jars when I made a smoothie
last time so that anytime I make a
smoothie I could just easily put this in
and I don't have to worry about all of
the things that are in here so in here
I've got some protein powder I have
greens powder spirulina powder hemp
seeds chia seeds and I even have a goji
berries and I think I also have some
flax seeds in here as well so it's full
of a lot of really good things and I
like to always add these into my
smoothies but quite often I get lazy and
I don't want to take every single thing
out if you want to make it easier on
yourself just prep a portion in it
that's like a super awesome idea I have
never thought about doing that myself
but yeah it's like if you're a smoothie
person and you want all these different
kind of add-ins to your smoothie
assuming they're all like shelf-stable
then why not like put them into little
baggies put them into jars that way you
just like literally grab one every
single day throw it into the blender
with your you know your your milk or
your fruit or whatever else is going in
there I think it's a really great
time-saving hack and that we don't need
to slep all the things out of the pantry
I get that that is a big pain in the ass
as for this smoothie concoction I mean
there's a lot of supplements here some
of which are kind of expensive like the
greens powder or the goji berries or
spirulina and things like that so not so
cheap miss cheap lacy vegan but I would
say that I'm happy she's getting a lot
of you know protein in there some
healthy fats lots of antioxidants she's
even got iron in there which I know is
like a little bit more hard to plan on a
plant-based diet so I think that's
really great and ultimately in the world
of smoothies this is a lot more balanced
than all the kind of like fruit only
smoothies I've seen on a lot of vegan
channels so thumbs up ginger as well cuz
apparently Ginger's good for you I've
got some frozen berries I'm going to add
in I have a frozen banana as always I
even have some frozen spinach and I'm
going to also add probably some almond
milk oh my god look what I've done
no all the blueberries hi second roll
five-second rule I'm totally okay with
that oh when you bury you pick them up
them up again and probably wash them a
lot
I'm also going to add one date because I
want to sweeten it up and here's the
piece of ginger just one date
I can honestly compassion like freely
doing a response video on how there's
just not enough dates and you need to
you need to carb up rose
no but seriously from my perspective one
date is like a totally reasonable amount
of dates to be putting in a smoothie
unlike some other youtubers that have
different opinions but I think it's
dates are a really great way to add
natural sweetness and that way you don't
actually have to add in any kind of
sugar or maple syrup or agave or honey
or anything like that
so that's awesome I mean can we just
take a moment to appreciate a balanced
smoothie for once on the internet this
is so much better than a lot of the
smoothies I've seen on other youtubers
channels this one has a lot going on
we've got spinach without vegetables we
got banana got berries we got almond
milk we've got that powder situation so
we've got protein in there lots of
healthy fats the iron I'm just happy to
see a balanced smoothie for once in the
vegan YouTube space and because it has
that fiber and protein and fat in there
I think this one's gonna actually keep
rose satiated for a lot longer than the
just plain old banana and date smoothies
I've seen one piece of toast with some
hummus and lots of other sprout
now looks great simple honestly very
good smoothie looks like I mean it
always looks like a bunch of sludge but
let's see how it tastes so Real Talk the
best smoothies and life look like sledge
true story but yeah that breakfast as a
whole looks great it's well-balanced
we've got you know various food groups
represented it doesn't feel overly
restrictive we've got some protein we've
got some fiber we've got some
antioxidants we've got some good fats in
there I really like it I think it looks
very satisfying and healthy and well
balanced also this is so easy no it
doesn't look like an Instagram styled
video but this is real life so Bravo you
can make myself a bit of a salad type
situation I have some leftover lasagna
but I think I see what I could do all
right
I love it we're freestyling let's see
what's for lunch but some Chinese
broccoli but I definitely need to use
that I might throw in some baby bok choy
as well because I think that's also lady
going back 20 strongly that kind of
looks like I mean it's not the freshest
but you know what I'm sure if I were to
stir-fry it and then I have some tofu
this is medium firm tofu that let's see
what I can make I think I'm gonna do a
sope noodle thing okay
I'm doing some soba noodles Chinese
broccoli tofu and maybe some bok choy
let's see what we can make sounds
awesome I love just kind of like working
with what you have in the fridge and
pantry on the fly and that's honestly
how I cook as well and it's especially
when things are kind of like at the edge
of their their life and you need to kind
of use them up before you just end up
chucking them in the garbage so yay for
reducing waste so I get how daunting it
may seem to like not follow recipe not
follow set of rules and like not follow
instructions and just kind of like
something on the fly but like everything
that's kind of just like a skill that
you you kind of develop with practice so
the more you can get into the kitchen
and just kind of like go for it the more
comfortable you're going to be already
shrunk down a lot I'm just going to see
it then with some soy sauce sesame oil
and I'm gonna add a bit of maple syrup
cuz I think it's gonna be quite bitter
that looks awesome
I love Chinese broccoli and bok choy but
you know honestly they're a great source
of fiber folate vitamin A vitamin K
calcium and Chinese broccoli also has
some omega-3 ala content so yay I love
that Rose is steaming her vegetables
here it is like one of my favorite ways
to cook mainly because it helps to
really retain some of the nutrients
better than let's say boiling where a
lot of those kind of water soluble
nutrients can be leached into the water
especially if we like over boil and
overcook them as like let's say our
grandparents used to but when it comes
to kind of cooking versus raw
I mean I've talked about this before and
I'll briefly touch on it again some
fruits and vegetables are better raw
from a nutrient perspective others are
better when they're cooked some foods
are kind of more tough and the fibers
are tough so cooking them helps to break
them down and make them more easy to
digest so that those nutrients are just
more bioavailable to us honestly at the
end of the day my recommendation is to
just try to get a variety of fruits and
vegetables into your day because that is
the most important thing
[Music]
right here I'm gonna cook up the tofu I
also just want to kind of quickly point
out that I like that
Rosa suggested using like a hint of
maple syrup to counterbalance the
bitterness of greens because a lot of
people would try greens on their own
steamed for example maybe without salt
or sugar or fat and think this tastes
terrible
I've never tried this again but sugar is
just another tool in the chef's toolbox
there's no need to be completely
irrationally scared of a little bit of
sugar or salt or fat you know including
these things in moderation is a great
way to enhance the natural flavors of a
lot of these naturally nourishing foods
I get that like the joys of being a
blogger this is so hard to do with like
one hand and cooking this is why I like
like I totally fail at my own wedding in
the day videos it's too much for me too
much coordination believe it or it's a
cook I'm gonna leave it on medium high
heat cook it for about like four minutes
on each side let's see what happens
after four minutes in the meantime my
water is boiling so I'm gonna throw in
at these open arrows and that only takes
about five minutes to cook the Chinese
broccoli and ibaka Toria looks like it's
very much reduced I'm just gonna add
tiny bit of sesame oil look a little
there it left
I'm just hoping these parts are softened
all right I'm gonna try and use these
it's still pretty soft I think ah but
look at that I mean I couldn't leave it
on for a bit longer but I'm also
impatient so let's
[Music]
yeah that was a nail-biter folks
honestly if it was me I would be tempted
just like add some more oil to the pan
because I'm just like I could see the
tofu wanting to just like hold on to
that pan and not let go without a mess
so that would I mean my instinct but I'm
glad we like got through that so I love
that roast is always trying to get like
a satisfying source of protein in her
diet and in this case we're talking
about tofu or soy protein
I mean soy has gotten a bad reputation
in my opinion unnecessarily there's a
lot of people out there saying that it
causes cancer and thyroid issues and
infertility when Ashley the evidence
shows that soy actually has a lot of
health benefits even for non vegans in
fact for most people sois actually been
shown to have protective effects against
things like cancer it also has been
shown to have a lot of heart-healthy
effects and then it helps lower
triglycerides and cholesterol
particularly LDL cholesterol which is
considered the bad cholesterol I have an
entire video all about soy so if you're
interested seeing that you can check it
out right here and then I should be done
all right we're also going to make a
quick sauce we are taking some coaches
our Korean red pepper paste that's what
it looks like Korean hot pepper paste
we're also gonna take some apple cider
vinegar sesame oil maple syrup and so
one of the things I really love about
Rose's meal here is that she's exploring
a variety of cooking techniques she's
boiling the noodles she's steaming the
vegetables
she's pan frying the tofu so if you're a
beginner cook who's watching Rose at
home just kind of trying to follow along
you actually can learn quite a lot and
honestly while I personally cannot
imagine like dirtying three pants or
pots at the same time in the middle of
like a workday mommy don't have time for
that
anymore you could theoretically be doing
all of this in batch prep on the weekend
for example in like large quantities you
can just kind of assemble throughout the
week because each component is like very
very simple as you can see it doesn't
require any kind of like really fancy
equipment or really kind of over-the-top
techniques or cooking skills to be able
to pull this off but not least we're now
some green onions these are just chopped
green onions and there is the finished
Bowl there are some spicy noodles I love
a good noodle shot and now I'm like
really craving noodles so maybe that's
what I'm having for dinner tonight but
this looks great and and true to her
name
cheap I don't know if it's lazy but
definitely cheap and vegan but also
really easy actually as well so Bravo I
love that the floor blueberries are back
and they're looking mighty shiny so
they've clearly been washed thoroughly
so that's great food safety number one
but also can't falter on that I mean
blueberries are fantastic
snack they're rich in antioxidants and
fiber they're naturally sweet and I
appreciate that she's consuming them in
their whole state and in a reasonable
portion as well we're not like bringing
in like like a literally fruit markets
full of blueberries to consume as a
snack so this looks great to me
I just wash them thoroughly guys I'm
going to take my vitamins I am actually
terrible at remembering to take vitamins
I do try to take b12 as often
I can remember and this is just a
mixture of different vitamins I know
there's b12 in here I think that there
is some sort of omega-3 saying I think
there's also vitamin D although I could
be wrong anyways just like a mixture of
different vitamin I'm just going to take
them and yeah just remember to take your
b12 guys thank you Thank You rose
because honestly so many youtubers out
there are not talking about supplements
and I love that you're explicitly saying
hey don't forget about your b12
supplement because b12 is found in
animal products it's not naturally found
in plant-based foods so of course it is
very important to make sure that you're
taking a supplement if you're following
a plant-based vegan diet also she
mentions she's taking vitamin D though
I'm not sure that she is just because I
know what these things look like and I
don't see a supplement there that looked
like vitamin D so maybe she forgot that
day but we're in Canada we're in Canada
and we usually do need vitamin D but of
course always speak to your doctor about
that in terms of omega threes again I
think that's a really important one
not just for vegans but honestly for a
lot of people there are very few really
rich sources of omega threes in the diet
particularly when we're talking about
EPA and DHA however for your own
information we can now find a APA and
DHA omega-3 that is vegan in a lot of
kind of health food stores and drug
stores so speak to your pharmacist speak
to your doctor and they will help you
find the right supplement for you and if
you want to see some of the ones that I
like you can check out my Amazon
affiliate link below okay so let's see
what Rose is having for dinner guys I
have been working all day it's been
pretty busy so I'm working an hour she
just went to the gym and I just got that
and I kind of want to do something with
cauliflower I always get some sort with
like charred cauliflower at restaurants
and I kind of want to try making that as
part with like a dinner obviously it's
not ever gonna be a full dinner
who eats cauliflower for dinner like
please yeah I kinda want to try making
charred cauliflower because I have
cauliflower left and I'm like okay
should I try and char this even though I
don't really know how to char I think
I'm gonna throw a weight onto it pan for
a bit I just love how real she is and
how adventurous she is in the kitchen
you know I love taking inspiration from
restaurants and meals that I've had
while traveling abroad and when I get
home I'm like oh I have this photo of
this beautiful dish that I had in this
beautiful restaurant I want to find a
way to recreate it maybe add some more
nutrition in it add some more fiber add
some more veggies to the meal kind of
put my own spin on it and some of my
best recipes have kind of been born out
of that and when we test recipes at
Abby's kitchen let me tell you it is not
always easy it's not always a walk in
the park they don't always come out
perfectly in the first go there are
times where we have ten different
batches of a recipe before we've said
yeah this actually tastes really good it
worked out perfectly this is the right
cooking time so I appreciate that she
has this like kind of like no fear
approach to cooking whereas like she
doesn't actually know exactly what she's
doing but she's willing to jump in there
give it a go and kind of walk you
through that that adventure in that
process and it's really fun to watch
[Music]
I'm actually gonna use olive oil maybe
we've washed the pan for food safety
purposes
[Music]
so I'm gonna make sure this is on high
heat I don't know if this is gonna work
it might just cook it
all right let's oh my god it's like whoa
I think it's kind of burnt because I
didn't wash the pan but it's kind of
looking in my favor right now with my
new bathroom labor foam cut whatever I
had before
you
so this meal looks great I mean
basically we've got everything you want
here we've got lots of vegetables we've
got some pan-fried tofu with barbecue
sauce looks like some frozen corn and
edamame which is a really economical
easy choice so it really does speed up
the dinner if you can rely on some of
those freezer staples so love that as a
little tip one of the things that really
stands out to me is that Rosa's meals
feel like they're appropriately
portioned to kind of be satisfied to her
probably also would be pretty satisfying
to me as well but I find that there's a
lot of youtubers out there recommending
these huge portions that take up an
entire dinner table and that's just not
realistic or necessary for a lot of
people so I love that Rose is just
keeping it real and normalizing her diet
okay so let's take a look at Rose's
nutritional breakdown as a whole
Rose is getting approximately seventeen
hundred and thirty eight calories with
23% of her energy coming from protein
42% coming from carbs and 31% coming
from fat overall I would say that Rose's
diet is like really well balanced and
seemingly well thought out even though
it doesn't seem like she's actually like
thinking really hard or planning or
following a set of rules it actually
seems quite intuitive and kind of like
she just kind of goes with the flow
which is awesome
Rosa's diet is also really high in fiber
she's getting about 50 grams in her day
which is amazing she's also getting a
lot of omega-3s
even without the supplement and getting
adequate amounts of calcium iron and B
vitamins which can be difficult ones to
get on a completely plant-based diet so
that's amazing plus with all the
different sources of protein in her day
she's also getting all nine essential
amino acids soy for example is a
plant-based source of protein with all
of the amino acids so that's incredible
if I were to eat like Rose for a day I
think I would probably be very happy and
very satisfied so let's talk about what
I like about Rose's diet number one her
recipes are simple and delicious looking
I love that Rose is not fussing over
these elaborate recipes everything seems
accessible
easy relatively quick to put together
there aren't a ton of crazy ingredients
with the exception of some of the
supplements that she has in her smoothie
in the morning but for the most part
this feels like something that even I
could pull off on my craziest busy mama
working mom days so for that I think she
really does make veganism seem very
inviting and accessible number two she
explores a variety of ingredients and
meal ideas so I think when we watch a
lot of these youtubers healthy meal
ideas and videos we see a lot of the
same recipes right smoothie bowls
avocado toast juices you know and I'm
sure like maybe maybe Rose eats all of
those things too and that's great but I
appreciate that we actually got to see
kind of some of her South Korean roots
come through and all these recipes seem
really fun and unique and enjoyable I
think a lot of us have this kind of
whitewash idea of what healthy food is
or what vegan food is and we shouldn't
be afraid to experiment with all these
other delicious cultural cuisines so I'm
just really appreciative of all of these
great ideas that I feel like I've walked
away with and I'm gonna try to
incorporate into my meal prep and
planning for the weeks ahead and finally
she sends out really positive nutrition
and food vibes I mean all of the things
that Rose talks about makes veganism
feel very approachable
very accessible even easy
so I really think that's amazing she
just likes good food and believes it
should taste great and that's awesome I
also find that it's not overtly preachy
in her philosophy she's not cutting out
full food groups while still maintaining
a balanced plant-based diet so it seems
like she's literally just eating in a
way that makes her feel good and it
makes me want to have a meatless meal so
she's doing a great job as for what I
don't love honestly I kind of like
wracked my brain to think about like was
there anything in this video that I
wasn't loving and I couldn't really
think of much however what I will say is
that I just feel
she has such an intuitive approach to
eating I would hate to see her throw
that away and get sucked into dye
culture with this kind of like fitness
challenge int like entry and fasting
diet that she was kind of like trying
later on in her in her journey on her
YouTube channel just stick with what
works and what is working is listening
to your body and I think that that above
all is the best measure of health so
stick to it Rose come back to me so guys
I hope you enjoyed this episode of what
I in a day you to review if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with any other youtubers
that you want me to review don't forget
to check out my entire playlist of some
more what a imagej videos subscribe to
the channel don't forget that and share
this with your friends and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye